Here's a typical best practice for
using ListView.
You feed it with some sort of
an adapter, like a CursorAdapter,
which you feed with a CursorLoader and
you register an OnItemClickListener
with the ListView to get notified
when the list item is clicked.
And, you might have used a ViewHolder
pattern to help you populate views with
that CursorAdapter.
Well, using RecyclerView, we see some
familiar faces, like CursorLoader.
Where ViewHolder was an optional but
recommended part of the ListView
pattern, it's a required and integral
part of the RecyclerView pattern.
Now we don't have a CursorAdapter at the
moment, and that's not such a terrible
thing, because now that we have
CursorLoader doing the work of reloading
our cursors when content changes,
CursorAdapter didn't do all that much.
We also don't have
an OnItemClickListener.
Now, one could use the
OnItemTouchListener along with a gesture
detector to determine when an item is
clicked, but it's more common to just
have your view holder implement
an OnItemClickListener for
the individual views that it's holding.
The ViewHolder has access to the Adapter
position that has been clicked.
And since it is typically
an inner class ViewAdapter,
it would also have access to
the adapter data for click handling.
Let's show how this works in practice.
In onCreateViewHolder from our adapter,
we inflate the appropriate layout for
the view type.
Note that our sample ViewHolder can
change references to the views.
Just like we would have done in
the old school ViewHolder pattern.
In on create ViewHolder from our
adapter, when we create the ViewHolder,
we have to pass the root
view into the superclass.
We then can start references to
the child views we want to fill out
if we wish.
This is also a good place to
set the OnClickListener for
the view, note that we have to have our
viewHolder implement the OnClickListener
to use this pattern in this way.
And when we bind the ViewHolder, we
take advantage of our ViewHolder being
a non-static interclass for Adaptor,
so it has access to our data.
In this case, a cursor.